so throughout my PhD I had to get
definitely a lot better at coding so
throughout this video I'm going to give
you three tips to upgrade your coding
game and to get in the flow always and
have deep working sessions throughout
your life so let's get straight into it
so in general if I have a good coding
day I would say it looks something like
this I have one deep working session in
the morning one day working session in
the afternoon and sometimes one deep
working session in the evening and if I
have one in the evening that is
definitely a really good day so a deep
working session refers to a period of
focus and uninterrupted work during
which an individual engages in highly
concentrated and productive work it's a
state of flow where one can fully
immerse themselves in a task maintaining
high levels of concentration and
engagement and I think this is the most
important so during coding you don't
only want to spend the time but you also
want to have the full attention and
there are several ways to increase your
attention whilst also increasing the
amount of coding time that you spend so
one of the things that I immediately
want to recommend to is to work with
chat GPT and of course there has been
quite a lot of disruption by GPT and
also by the code interpreter for example
saying that data Sciences will be
replaced pretty soon
and I don't think this is true I think
actually that chat GPT won't replace
programmers or data scientists I think
actually data scientists and programmers
that use chat GPT will replace people
that don't know how to use it so I
definitely highly recommend to keep up
to date with the latest news and try the
tools out yourself so there are two that
I quite like within Ai and that's just
jgpt and the code interpreter and notion
AI both of them I use quite a lot for my
programming and for my thinking during
my PhD so in general I kind of use it as
a rubber duck so the idea is that when a
programmer encounters a problem or a bug
in their code they explain the issue
step by step to an inanimate objects
such as a rubber duck as if they were
teaching how to solve the problem and
that's kind of how I use jgpt not as my
teacher but more as my co-programmer or
like a programming assistant and I
definitely think this can help you stay
in your workflow because I noticed
before that sometimes I would really get
bogged down onto one really specific
problem and now I can just ask Chachi PT
and get over that little hump really
fast so I also wanted to give a little
shout out to you PDF the sponsor of
today's video so I've been using new PDF
for a little while now to annotate all
my PDF files and one feature that I
personally really really like is that
you can actually add text to already
existing PDF files so if you need to
adjust a PDF or just put in some
mnemonics such that you can remember the
PDF a little bit better this is an
amazing feature another tool that
they've added lately is AI such that you
can make custom bullet points of your
PDF files or even translate it fully to
another language which I think is super
duper cool so check the new PDF out and
they've also given a discount code for
all my subscribers such that you can get
54 of your first purchase such that you
can use all the pro features so check
your PDF out and let's get straight back
into the video
no programming for long hours can
definitely be really challenging and I
think one of the most challenging bits
is that it can be quite repetitive
without knowing exactly what the end
goal is so one of the ways that I solve
that is to have really clear goals and
of course people always say like you
need to have these really practical
goals but I can definitely imagine if
you're like me and you're working more
in a high level programming field that
you don't always know what your goals
are so for me what I always have in mind
are actually the visual images that I
want my code to spit out in a sense so
for example if I do an optimization
problem I always have the final
optimization image in my mind that I
want to create or if I am creating a
deep neural network I kind of have in
mind what kind of shape I want the data
output to be at the end and the same is
now I'm working on a genetics project
and I usually have pretty clear in my
mind what I want the final images to be
like and I think This is highly
dependent if you're more a visual or a
person or more a person that thinks in
language but I think if you are a visual
person and you usually think more in
images and less in text I think it's
really good to create kind of like a
vision board as if you're creating a
script for a movie for each step of your
coding program and that you want to see
what it will give out and I think also
that makes the whole entire coding game
way more a creative process instead of
solely a cognitive process and also
something that I've really learned
during my PhD is these kind of triggers
that get you into the Flow State pretty
easily and I think that is to keep your
environment always the same so I used to
be as a student I used to love going to
coffee shops for example or going to
different places and code everywhere I
could but I think as a PhD student I
kind of realized that it's a little bit
better to have a few set places that you
can get into the same mindset and that
you do the same work every day so it's
kind of this idea of having your perfect
environment and I don't think this has
to be like some expensive cafe or like
you have to get a really expensive desk
setup but I think actually for me the
best is just to go to university and
work at my desk there and because I go
there every day lately I really notice
that every time that I go there it's
pretty easy to enter into this full
focused Zone Without Really Trying too
hard and if you're working on the
attention or Focus I recommend this
video next and otherwise see you next
week bye